In Janah Boccio's Health and Human Relations class, they're studying puberty now. And for the entire period, the sixth-grade boys are a squirming, moving, fidgeting, chatty mess.
在Janah Boccio的健康与人际关系课上，学生们正在学习青春期。在整个课时里，六年级的男生们一直处于扭动、挪动、躁动不安和叽叽喳喳的混乱状态。
[STUDENTS LAUGHING]
[学生们的笑声]
And can I say, as they get deeper into the material, they do not seem to see much of an upside to puberty at all, anywhere. When they notice that one of the books uses the word "enjoyable" to describe sex, one boy declares...
我可以这么说吗？随着他们对教材理解的深入，他们似乎完全看不出青春期有什么好的地方。当他们注意到其中一本书用“愉悦”来形容性行为时，一个男孩宣布……
I don't think so. That's disgusting.
我不这么认为，真恶心。
Why are you saying that?
你为什么这么说？
Because it's disgusting.
因为它很恶心。
And when Miss Boccio asked the boys if they're looking forward to any part of puberty--
当Boccio老师问男生们是否期待青春期的任何部分时——
Growing in height, not anything else.
长高，其他什么都不期待。
OK.
好吧。
A lot of things are growing.
很多东西都在长。
So is there anything that you're not looking forward to?
那么有什么是你所不期待的吗？
Yeah--
有——
I'm not looking forward to pubic hair.
我不期待长阴毛。
Why?
为什么？
Because it might be weird.
因为那可能会很奇怪。
What else are you not looking forward to?
还有什么你不期待的吗？
Sweating more, a lot more.
出汗更多，多得多。
Chest hair. Chest hair.
胸毛。胸毛。
OK.
好吧。
Getting really smelly.
变得真的很臭。
Chest hair.
胸毛。
Sweating like a moose.
出汗像头驼鹿。
You're going to smell more bad. You're going to sweat. Your shirt is going to get all sweaty. It's going to get worse.
你会变得更臭。你会出汗。你的衬衫会变得全是汗。情况会变得更糟。
Yeah, because when I was younger, it didn't smell like this.
是的，因为我小时候，身上没有这种味道。
I know, it smelled nice. You smelled better. Now, you smell bad.
我知道，那时候味道很好。你闻起来更清爽。现在，你闻起来很糟糕。
They said that shaving seems like it's going to be a drag, which, by the way, good call, kids. Several boys squealed that the illustration of pubic hair in the book looked like burnt macaroni and cheese. Near the end of class, one of the kids, Jack, told me that part of what's so freaky is that you just don't know when puberty is going to strike you.
他们说刮胡子听起来很麻烦，顺便说一句，孩子们，说得好。几个男生尖叫道，书里关于阴毛的插图看起来就像烤焦的通心粉和奶酪。快下课时，其中一个孩子Jack告诉我，最让人害怕的部分是你根本不知道青春期什么时候会袭击你。
It's scary because it's not like a set date and time. It can happen when you're 8 or happen when you're 16. So you're not 100% prepared. It's like a mysterious monster. You know it's going to get you.
这很可怕，因为它不像设定好的日期和时间。它可能发生在你8岁时，也可能发生在16岁时。所以你并没有百分之百的准备。它就像一个神秘的怪物。你知道它迟早会找上你。
It's going to hit you at one point.
它迟早会袭击你。
So it's like, you know that there's this thing that's coming to get you. You don't know when it's going to be, and you're going to be totally different on the other side of it.
所以这就像，你知道有个东西正冲你而来。你不知道它什么时候会到，而在它过后，你将变得完全不同。
Yeah.
是的。
On the opposite end of the country, in Northern California, 10-year-old Paris was at a similar class, a class about puberty for moms and girls. And she described the approaching monster in different terms that got across pretty much the same idea.
在国家的另一端，北加州，10岁的Paris正在参加一个类似的课程，一个为妈妈和女孩们开设的青春期课程。她用不同的词汇描述了这个即将到来的怪物，但表达的意思基本相同。
It's a little scary, almost. I guess it's a little like on the edge of a cliff. Like, there's a really good movie coming out, and you're just about to see it. But people say that it can be either bad or good, and you're not really sure which.
这有点吓人。我想这就像站在悬崖边上。就像有一部非常好的电影即将上映，而你正要去看它。但人们说它可能很糟糕，也可能很好，你并不确定会是哪种。
Paris told the reporter that she talked to, Marianne McCune, that she was one of the first ones in her class to hit puberty, which of course is not fun. Like most kids, I think, she did not like looking different from everybody else.
Paris告诉她采访的记者Marianne McCune，她是班里最早进入青春期的孩子之一，这当然一点也不好玩。像大多数孩子一样，我想，她不喜欢自己看起来与众不同。
It's like, you don't want it to happen. You want your body to stay the same. You don't want your body to look gross. And so it's kind of gross being different. Yeah, I really didn't want to.
这就像，你不希望它发生。你希望你的身体保持原样。你不希望你的身体看起来恶心。所以与众不同有点让人反感。是的，我真的不希望它发生。
Did you think there might be a way out?
你认为有什么办法可以逃避吗？
No, I didn't think there was going to be a way out. I was hoping that there would be some type of medicine or something that I could take, and it would go away. But no, it didn't really work that way.
不，我不认为有逃避的方法。我曾希望有什么药或之类的东西可以吃，然后它就会消失。但没有，它并不是那样运作的。
A lot of kids feel this way. In these classes, they ask the teachers, why does this have to happen, and is there any way I can stay a kid? It's crazy to be told you can't do anything about this. It's coming. And when it happens, everything will be different. How many things in our lives are like that?
很多孩子都有这种感觉。在这些课程中，他们问老师，为什么一定要发生这种事，有没有什么办法能让我保持孩子模样？被告知你对这一切束手无策真的很疯狂。它正在到来。当它发生时，一切都会改变。我们生活中还有多少事是这样的呢？
Well, today, on our show, we have stories of people dealing with the inevitable, trying to do their best, trying to stay themselves through these things that can be so confusing and potentially soul-crushing. And we're not going to mess around today with little inevitable things in life, with traffic and relatives you don't like and what happens if you never brush your teeth.
今天，在我们的节目中，我们将讲述人们如何应对不可避免的事情，试图尽力而为，试图在这些可能令人困惑甚至可能摧毁灵魂的事情中保持自我。今天我们不会去讨论生活中那些无关紧要的不可避免的小事，比如交通堵塞、你不喜欢的亲戚，或者如果你从不刷牙会发生什么。
No, no, no. We're going to go with the big ones. We're going to go with two inescapable things that are absolutely certain. Act 1 of our show is about death. Act 2 is about taxes. These are two things that are unavoidable, that actually I think most of us don't know that much about. And today we turn to people who know more than us. Prepare to be surprised at what they say.
不，不，不。我们要讨论重头戏。我们要讨论两件绝对必然的、不可逃避的事情。我们节目的第一幕是关于死亡。第二幕是关于税收。这是两件不可避免的事情，事实上，我认为我们大多数人对它们了解并不多。今天我们将向那些比我们了解更多的人请教。准备好对他们所说的感到惊讶吧。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。请留下来。
Act 1, Death. So we can only guess at what happens to us after we die, but we do not have to guess at what happens right before. Though most of us remain ignorant until we arrive at that moment ourselves, Nancy Updike found a spot where she could understand all this better. Here's Nancy.
第一幕，死亡。所以我们只能猜测死后会发生什么，但我们不必猜测临死前会发生什么。尽管我们大多数人在自己到达那个时刻之前都处于无知状态，但Nancy Updike找到了一个地方，让她能更好地理解这一切。这是Nancy的讲述。
Before I tell you where I went, let me tell you why I wanted to go. Four years ago, my mother's husband, Asa, was dying. She was taking care of him at home with help from a hospice. And I went to be with her and him for the last 10 days of his life.
在我告诉你我去了哪里之前，让我先告诉你我为什么想去。四年前，我母亲的丈夫Asa正在走向死亡。她在临终关怀的帮助下在家照顾他。我去陪了她和他度过他生命中最后的10天。
He was this tall, very funny man with beautiful manners who adored my mother. I felt clumsy and helpless all the time in those last days-- with Asa, with my mom. I didn't know what to say to someone who's dying. I didn't know how to be. I'm sure that's true for lots of people.
他是个个子很高、非常幽默、举止优雅、深爱我母亲的人。在那最后的日子里，我一直感到笨拙而无助——无论对Asa还是我母亲。我不知道该对一个濒死的人说些什么。我不知道该如何自处。我相信这对很多人来说都是如此。
I remember checking in on Asa one afternoon and asking him if he needed anything. He looked at me and said, I need everything. We both laughed. That was the closest I ever got to talking with him about what was happening.
记得有一天下午，我去探望Asa，问他是否需要什么。他看着我说，我需要一切。我们都笑了。那是我和他谈论所发生的事情时最接近的一次。
There were people around who did know what to do, though-- the nurses. I watched them from my stupor of awkwardness. They never brought any false cheer into the room with Asa, which is hard not to do with a dying person. They were direct. When Jackie, the weekend day nurse, left the Sunday before Asa died, she said to him, is it OK if I kiss your hand? And then she said, God willing, I'll see you next week.
然而，身边确实有知道该怎么做的人——护士们。我在那种笨拙的恍惚中观察她们。她们从不对Asa表现出任何虚假的快乐，而这在面对临终者时是很难做到的。她们很直接。当周末白班护士Jackie在Asa去世前的那个周日离开时，她对他说了，我能亲吻你的手吗？然后她说，上帝保佑，希望下周还能见到你。
The nurses knew how to deal with us, the rest of the family, too. One of the nurses, Jenny, got me cleaning out the fridge one morning. We did it together for an hour and a half, just talking, passing the time. It wasn't until later that I realized, oh, she did that for me, to give me something to do. It was a strange feeling to know I was that transparent to her.
护士们也知道如何应付我们这些家属。其中一位护士Jenny有天早上让我去清理冰箱。我们一起干了一个半小时，只是聊聊天，打发时间。直到后来我才意识到，噢，她是为我做的，是为了给我找点事做。知道自己对她而言如此透明，这种感觉很奇怪。
For the last hour of Asa's life, the people in the room were my mother, one of Asa's sons, Jenny, and me. We held Asa's hands. Jenny was standing, and she sometimes touched Asa's head gently. She told him, it's all right. It's OK. Your family is OK. Everyone is all right. Asa's eyes were open. They'd been that way all day. He was staring up and to the right, over our heads. He didn't see us. He moaned every once in a while, and we spoke to him when he moaned. The four of us watched his breathing slow down and get shallower until he was taking just sips of air.
在Asa生命中的最后一个小时里，房间里的人有我的母亲、Asa的一个儿子、Jenny和我。我们握着Asa的手。Jenny站着，她有时轻轻触碰Asa的头。她告诉他，没关系。一切都好。你的家人很好。每个人都很好。Asa的眼睛睁着。它们整天都是那样。他一直向上和向右盯着，越过我们的头顶。他看不见我们。他偶尔会呻吟，每当他呻吟时，我们就会对他说话。我们四个人看着他的呼吸变慢，变得越来越浅，直到他只能像啜饮空气一样呼吸。
When he was very close to the end, Jenny brought over a glass of water and a little dropper that we'd been using to moisten Asa's mouth. And she told us each to take the dropper and give him some water and say our names close to his ear so that he would know who was giving him each bit of water. As a ritual, it felt comforting and sad and vaguely religious. And Asa's son and I were both crying. I had no idea how badly we'd needed a ritual at that moment until Jenny gave us one.
当他临近生命尽头时，Jenny拿来一杯水和一个小滴管，我们一直用它来润湿Asa的嘴。她告诉我们每个人轮流使用滴管给他喂点水，并在他耳边轻声说出我们的名字，这样他就知道是谁喂了他每一滴水。作为一种仪式，它让人感到既安慰又悲伤，还有一种隐约的宗教感。Asa的儿子和我都哭了。直到Jenny给了我们这个仪式，我才知道那一刻我们有多么需要它。
I had never seen the kind of expertise these nurses had. They knew death. They seemed to understand it, whereas I-- even though I had just watched someone fade away and die right in front of me, all I could think was, what just happened?
我从未见过这些护士拥有的那种专业知识。她们了解死亡。她们似乎理解它，而我——尽管我刚刚目睹了某人在我面前消逝并离去，我能想到的只有，刚刚发生了什么？
But I didn't realize how much of a hold all of this had on me still until I heard a stranger talking a few months ago about how his mother is a nurse who works in a hospice facility, seeing people die almost every day.
但我直到几个月前听到一个陌生人谈论他的母亲，一位在临终关怀机构工作的护士，几乎每天都目睹人们死亡，我才意识到这一切对我还有多大的影响。
And then he went on to say that after his mother had worked there for a few months, she forgot the president's name. And when she mentioned that to her boss, her boss said, yeah, that happens. That's normal here. Your brain is blocking out a lot of what you're seeing, and some other stuff is getting blocked, too. My first thought was, my god, of course. They're experts, not robots. My second thought was, I need to go to this place and talk to these people.
然后他接着说，他的母亲在那里工作几个月后，竟然忘了总统的名字。当她向老板提起这件事时，她的老板说，是的，这种事会发生。在这里这很正常。你的大脑正在屏蔽你所看到的大部分内容，其他一些东西也被屏蔽了。我的第一个念头是，天哪，当然了。她们是专家，不是机器人。我的第二个念头是，我需要去这个地方，和这些人谈谈。
Oop, this guy wants to pass me. Usually, nobody ever passes me. I'm on my best behavior with you in the car. [LAUGHS]
噢，这家伙想超我的车。通常从来没人超我的车。有你在车里，我的表现可是最好的。[笑声]
So this is Pattie Burnham. She's the one who forgot the president's name. That was five years ago, though. She's on top of it now. It's Barack Obama, by the way. Pattie is a registered nurse, and the place she works is an inpatient hospice about 30 minutes north of Boston called the Kaplan Family Hospice House. We're driving there now. Pattie's got a double shift today. I told her my whole backstory so she knows why I'm here.
这位就是Pattie Burnham。她就是那个忘了总统名字的人。不过那是五年前的事了。她现在状态很好。顺便说一句，总统是Barack Obama。Pattie是一位注册护士，她工作的地点是位于波士顿以北约30分钟路程的一家住院临终关怀机构，叫Kaplan家庭临终关怀院。我们正驱车前往那里。Pattie今天上双班。我告诉了她我所有的背景故事，所以她知道我为什么来这里。
Pattie is 5'8", blonde, full of energy, even though it's 6:00 AM. She's lived in this part of Massachusetts her whole life, worked at a hospital, then as a nurse at her kids' school. And then when they graduated, she was looking for another job, and she went to the Kaplan House.
Pattie身高5英尺8英寸，金发，充满活力，尽管现在才早上6点。她一生都住在马萨诸塞州的这个地区，在医院工作过，后来在孩子们的学校当过护士。等孩子们毕业后，她就在寻找另一份工作，然后去了Kaplan之家。
I pulled into the parking lot and thought, wow, this place is beautiful. And then I noticed, off to the left, there's sort of a back entrance, a garage entrance. And there were two funeral-home cars pulled up there waiting. And I just sat in the parking lot, staring at the house and staring at the cars and wondering what could possibly be going on in that building.
我驶进停车场，心想，哇，这个地方真漂亮。然后我注意到，在左侧，有一个类似后门的入口，一个车库入口。有两辆殡仪馆的车停在那里等着。我只是坐在停车场里，盯着那座房子和那些车，想知道那栋大楼里到底在发生什么。
Hospice can mean a building, like Kaplan, or home care, like Asa had. They both mean the same thing. The patient is not looking to be cured. It's palliative care for people at the end of their life.
临终关怀既可以指一栋大楼，比如Kaplan，也可以指家庭护理，就像Asa那样。它们意思相同。病人不再寻求治愈。这是为生命尽头的人提供的姑息治疗。
The Kaplan House actually is beautiful. All the rooms have big windows. The lobby and main common area have vaulted ceilings and skylights. Nothing is covered in plastic. I overheard one family member of a patient say, the thing I like about this place is, there isn't a phony plant in here. All the flowers are real. There's a big kitchen for any patients who can still eat. Pattie speed-walks by.
Kaplan之家其实很美。所有的房间都有大窗户。大堂和主要公共区域有拱形天花板和天窗。没有任何东西被塑料覆盖。我无意中听到一位病人的家属说，我喜欢这个地方的一点是，这里没有一株假植物。所有的花都是真的。有一个大厨房供那些还能进食的病人使用。Pattie快步走过。
I need a fruit cup for room 4, please and thank you.
请给我来一份4号房间的水果杯，谢谢。
This is not just a place for rich people with private insurance. Lots of patients are on Medicare or Medicaid. Kaplan House is run by a nonprofit called Care Dimensions, and the bulk of what they do is home care. Kaplan House has rooms for just 20 patients. And it's not full today, but Pattie is busy. She rushes between rooms and then slows down as soon as she steps inside one.
这不仅仅是为有私人保险的富人准备的地方。许多病人使用的是医疗保险或医疗补助。Kaplan之家由一家名为Care Dimensions的非营利组织运营，他们大部分工作是家庭护理。Kaplan之家只有20个病人床位。今天没满，但Pattie很忙。她在房间之间穿梭，一旦走进房间，脚步就会放慢。
Does she look comfortable to you?
你看她看起来舒服吗？
Yes.
是的。
Pattie is talking to Crystal, the daughter of a 51-year-old woman named Lori who came to Kaplan House a few hours ago. She has lung cancer. It's metastasized to her brain. Lori is delirious, making sounds but not speaking much anymore. Her family has been taking care of her at home. They tell Pattie that Lori always liked to look good. She has a perfect red manicure and pedicure.
Pattie正在和Crystal交谈，这是一位51岁女性Lori的女儿，Lori几小时前才来到Kaplan之家。她患有肺癌。已经转移到了大脑。Lori处于谵妄状态，发出声音，但已经不太说话了。她的家人一直在家里照顾她。他们告诉Pattie，Lori一直喜欢把自己收拾得漂亮。她有完美的红色修指甲和足疗。
Yeah, you've been taking beautiful care of her. She looks beautiful.
是的，你们把她照顾得真好。她看起来很美。
[SNIFFLES]
[吸鼻涕]
If you want to chat about anything, if you have any questions about the medications or what's going on--
如果你想聊聊任何事，如果你对药物或现在的情况有任何问题——
Yeah.
是的。
--we can step outside. And you might not have any questions now, but they might come up.
——我们可以到外面去谈。你现在可能还没什么问题，但以后可能会有。
Right, yeah.
对，是的。
Right?
是吧？
Yup.
是的。
OK.
好吧。
The questions do come up. Crystal comes and finds Pattie, and she does something I remember doing. Crystal starts out asking about one small, specific thing to try and get a handle on what's happening. She wants to know, what is the tube that's on her mother's face right under her nose? She asks so quietly it's hard to hear. But she says, what's that thing on her nose? She smells like bleach.
问题确实会出现。Crystal来找Pattie，她做了一件我记得自己也做过的事情。Crystal起初问了一件很小、很具体的事情，试图掌握正在发生的情况。她想知道，她母亲鼻下插的那根管子是什么？她问得声音很小，很难听清。但她说，她鼻子上的那个东西是什么？她闻起来有漂白剂的味道。
What's that thing on her nose? She smells like bleach.
她鼻子上的那个东西是什么？她闻起来有漂白剂的味道。
Oxygen. That's just oxygen, yeah.
氧气。那只是氧气，是的。
This question-- basically, what is that thing on my mother's face that is making her look and smell like she's not my mother? That's just the first in a giant, unsorted pile of questions about what's happening and why, and what am I supposed to be doing and feeling? Crystal says some of the family and friends in the room have been saying that no one should touch Lori.
这个问题——基本上，我母亲脸上那个让她看起来和闻起来都不像是我母亲的东西是什么？这只是关于正在发生的事情、原因、以及我应该做什么和感受什么的巨大、混乱问题堆里的第一个。Crystal说房间里的一些家人和朋友一直在说不应该触碰Lori。
Not to touch her?
不要触碰她？
Yes.
是的。
You can touch her.
你可以触碰她。
From there, she tells Pattie, in one long, crying sentence, that people in the room have been telling her mother that it's OK to let go. And one of the times someone said it, her mother all of a sudden said, no. And what does that mean, since she's delirious?
接着，她以一连串哭泣的长句子告诉Pattie，房间里的人一直在告诉她母亲可以放手了。有一次有人说了这句话，她母亲突然说了，不。那意味着什么呢，既然她处于谵妄状态？
And should I be saying it's OK for her to let go? In some ways, I wish she would let go so she wouldn't suffer anymore, but I feel weird even thinking that. And my mom has gotten close to the end like this a few times before, and then she's come back. And maybe that's what's happening. And some people in the room are saying you guys are drugging her so that she'll die faster. And I don't know about any of this. I don't know. Pattie listens to the whole thing and then jumps in.
我是不是应该说让她放手没关系？在某些方面，我希望她放手，这样她就不再受苦了，但我甚至有这种想法都觉得奇怪。我妈妈以前也有几次像这样接近临终，但她又好转了。也许这就是正在发生的事情。房间里有些人说你们在给她用药，好让她死得快些。我对这一切一无所知。我不知道。Pattie听完了一切，然后插话道。
So a lot of people, Crystal, ask these questions. We are not drugging her to put her to sleep. I wouldn't do this job if that was the case. Your mom, I'm sorry to say, is dying. She has started her dying process. This is what-- everything you're seeing is part of the dying process.
所以很多人，Crystal，都会问这些问题。我们并没有为了让她入睡而给她用药。如果是那样的话，我就不会做这份工作了。很遗憾地告诉你，你母亲正在走向死亡。她已经开始了死亡进程。这就是——你所看到的一切都是死亡进程的一部分。
Because I know they keep saying, she's going to die. And she's done this, like, three or four times and got through it. And I'm just wondering what--
因为我知道他们一直在说，她要死了。她以前也像这样三四次，挺过来了。我只是在想什么——
So the things I'm seeing that makes me think that it's this time-- this is the time-- is her heart is beating really, really fast and just fluttering. You can't feel a good, strong pulse out here. Her legs and her hands are cold. Her feet-- it's showing a telltale sign that we see called mottling, where the feet and the knees get dappled, like little purplish marks. And it just means her body is conserving all her blood to be around here.
所以我看到这些迹象认为这次就是这样了——这次是时候了——是因为她的心跳非常非常快，而且只是在扑腾。你在这里摸不到有力而强健的脉搏。她的腿和手都是凉的。她的脚——这显示出我们称之为“斑驳”的明显迹象，脚和膝盖会出现斑点，像紫色的小印记。这意味着她的身体正在保留所有血液来维持核心器官。
I would bet my nursing license that your mother is not going to turn around from this. But if her body is meant to turn around, I'm not giving her anything that won't allow her to turn around. Does that make sense to you?
我敢用我的护理执照打赌，你母亲不会从这次状态中好转了。但如果她的身体注定要好转，我没有给她任何会阻止她好转的东西。这你能理解吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I remember standing with my mother and one of Asa's nurses in the kitchen and having this conversation, the this-is-it conversation. There are so many stages to a long decline-- dips and resurgences and good days. And you know-- you know it's all the same thing. It's all dying. But there's a huge difference between dying and the very last part of dying, what Pattie and the other nurses call actively dying, a process that can take hours or even days. But it's different from what comes before. And being familiar with one doesn't mean you'll recognize the other.
我记得曾和我的母亲以及Asa的一位护士站在厨房里进行过这样的对话，“就是现在了”的对话。漫长的衰退过程中有很多阶段——低谷、复苏和好转的日子。你知道——你知道这其实都是一回事。都在走向死亡。但死亡和死亡的最后一部分之间有巨大的区别，这就是Pattie和其他护士所说的“主动死亡”，这是一个可能持续数小时甚至数天的过程。但它与之前的情况不同。熟悉其中一种并不意味着你会识别另一种。
I talked to Pattie later, and I asked her how she knows when someone is actively dying. How does she know it so well that she would say, I'd bet my nursing license that this is what's happening?
我后来和Pattie谈过，我问她是怎么知道某人正在主动死亡的。她怎么能如此确信，以至于会说，我敢用我的护理执照打赌这就是正在发生的事？
I don't always feel that way. Yeah. It's a weird thing, because when I came to work at the Kaplan House-- and I was a registered nurse and had worked as a nurse for a while-- I followed another nurse, Jeannette, for a month. And I was floored by the whole dying process, because it was nothing that I had learned.
我并不总是那种感觉。是的。这很奇怪，因为当我刚来Kaplan之家工作时——我已经是一名注册护士，并且做了很长时间护士——我跟随另一位护士Jeannette一个月。我对整个死亡过程感到震惊，因为它和我学到的完全不同。
And I saw Jeanette say to a family-- she woke them up and said, he's dying. He's dying right now. And the man had been there-- the patient had been there for a week. And I didn't know what was different. I didn't know what she saw that was different. And when I asked her to explain it to me and to teach it to me, she said, you'll know. You just need about a month here, and you'll know.
我看到Jeannette对一个家庭说——她叫醒了他们并说，他正在死去。他现在正在死去。而那个人已经在那里了——那个病人已经在那里一周了。我不知道有什么不同。我不知道她看到了什么不同的东西。当我让她向我解释并教我时，她说，你会知道的。你只需要在这里待一个月，你就会知道。
I talked to a palliative-care doctor who told me that the most important thing she got better at with experience was looking for openings that allow you to be helpful-- little windows, little moments. With hospice, part of that is trying to help people take in, bit by bit, the realness of what's happening.
我采访过一位姑息治疗医生，她告诉我，她在经验中进步最大的一点是寻找那些让你有所帮助的契机——小窗户、小瞬间。在临终关怀中，这的一部分是试图帮助人们一点一点地接受正在发生之事的真实性。
Some dying people, no surprise, are not at all OK with the fact that they're dying. And they don't often get a chance to just say so. I saw a home-care nurse talking to a man, a former math teacher in his 60s. She was talking about antidepressants, asking him whether he was depressed. He thought about it, and he said, well, I'm not "jump out the window" depressed, more like, what the fuck happened?
一些濒死的人，毫不奇怪，对他们即将死去的事实完全不能接受。他们往往没有机会说出来。我看到一位家庭护理护士与一名男子交谈，一位60多岁的前数学老师。她正在谈论抗抑郁药，问他是否抑郁。他思考了一下，说，嗯，我还没到“跳出窗户”那种抑郁，更多像是，到底他妈的发生了什么？
Asa was a courtly man. I never heard him swear or even speak harshly in my life. But I could tell how frustrated he was sometimes by the sheer logistics of being a dying person, the imposition of it. Sometimes just the question, do you want this, seemed overwhelming. Dying is a constant series of judgment calls and decisions based on options that are very far from what anyone would want. And one thing the nurses are experienced at is trying to make the best of those narrow options.
Asa是一位彬彬有礼的人。我这辈子从未听过他说脏话，甚至说话从未严厉过。但我能看出他有时因为作为一个临终者的后勤繁琐事宜，以及它的强加而感到多么沮丧。有时仅仅是“你想要这个吗”的问题，似乎都让人难以承受。死亡是一系列不断的判断和选择，基于那些远非任何人想要的选项。而护士们经验丰富的一件事，就是试图在这些狭窄的选项中做到最好。
Joanne, it is no bother, first of all. And Christiana and I were going to do it together. I would love to give you a shower before you head home.
Joanne，首先，这不麻烦。Christiana和我本来打算一起做的。在你回家之前，我很乐意为你洗个澡。
Pattie is crouching next to a woman named Joanne, who's going home later today. She has lung cancer, and she's been getting hospice care at home. But her pain got worse, so she came to the Kaplan House for a few days of round-the-clock supervision while the doctors adjusted her pain medications.
Pattie正蹲在一位叫Joanne的女士旁边，她今天晚些时候就要回家了。她患有肺癌，一直在家接受临终关怀。但她的疼痛加重了，所以她来到Kaplan之家进行几天的全天候监控，同时医生调整她的止痛药。
People sometimes come in and out of Kaplan House like this. They're dying, but they still have time left in their lives. And the staff tries to get their symptoms under control-- pain or vomiting or whatever it is-- so that they can do more with that time than just be sick.
人们有时会像这样进出Kaplan之家。他们虽然在走向死亡，但生命中还有余下的时间。工作人员试图控制他们的症状——疼痛、呕吐或其他任何问题——这样他们就能利用这段时间做更多事，而不只是生病。
This room smells bad. It's strong. Joanne hasn't been able to shower in a little while. She said she has a hard time doing it at home. She's tiny in the bed, barely looking up, talking almost inaudibly. But her strength of will is intact. She knows the ambulance can't pick her up and take her home until later, but she wants to be home now, already. And anything that isn't going home is something she doesn't want to do, even though, a couple of hours ago, she was glad when Pattie suggested a shower, because it's much easier to do here when two people can get on either side of her and steady her.
这个房间闻起来很糟糕。味道很浓。Joanne有一段时间没能洗澡了。她说她在家里很难做到。她在床上显得很娇小，几乎不抬头，说话几乎听不清。但她的意志力还在。她知道救护车要晚些时候才能来接她回家，但她现在就想回家。任何不是回家的事情她都不想做，尽管几小时前，当Pattie建议洗澡时，她是很高兴的，因为在这里更容易做到，两个人可以站在她两侧稳住她。
I just feel like this is such a great opportunity, because it's so hard to do at home, and there's two of us here.
我只是觉得这是一个绝佳的机会，因为在家里很难做到，而且这里有我们两个人。
Why can't I take a shower in my own shower?
为什么我不能在自己的浴室里洗澡？
Do you do that regularly at home? Or is it hard because you need two people? Because you were telling me you don't feel that safe with the left side.
你在家里经常那样做吗？还是因为需要两个人所以很难？因为你告诉过我你觉得左侧不安全。
Yeah, but I do have-- what do you call it? I have that--
是的，但我有——你管那个叫什么来着？我有那个——
The bar that you hold onto and stuff, yeah. Want a back rub or--
你抓着的那个扶手之类的，是的。想要背部按摩吗，或者——
Yeah, maybe a neck rub.
是的，也许脖子按摩。
OK, OK. Yeah, it helps with your pain. We could put some lotion. Can we wash your back?
好吧，好吧。是的，这有助于缓解你的疼痛。我们可以抹点乳液。能洗洗你的后背吗？
Yeah.
可以。
Want to head into the bathroom? And you can sit on this in the bathroom. OK, let's do that.
想去浴室吗？你可以在浴室里坐在椅子上。好吧，我们这样做吧。
Maybe you can tell where Pattie is going with this. I'd seen her taking care of Joanne and others all day, people clearly in the midst of some of the worst days of their lives-- afraid, in pain, sick of being sick. And it takes serious skills to be able to nudge somebody in that situation toward a thing that they don't think they want but are very glad when they get it.
也许你能看出Pattie的用意。我整天看着她照顾Joanne和其他人，那些人显然正处于一生中最糟糕的日子里——恐惧、痛苦、厌倦了生病。需要极高的技巧才能引导处于那种境地的人去做他们认为自己不想做，但做完后却感到非常高兴的事情。
Can we take your pants down so she can get your backside?
我们要脱掉你的裤子，这样她能帮你洗背部吗？
[SHUFFLING]
[悉悉索索的声音]
All right, is that a comfortable position for you? Joanne, you do know we're getting pretty close to a shower.
好了，这对你来说是个舒服的姿势吗？Joanne，你知道我们很快就要洗澡了。
Yeah.
是的。
You sure you don't-- look at how--
你确定你不要——看看如何——
Go ahead.
去吧。
Go ahead. Whoo-hoo! Whoo-hoo!
去吧。呜呼！呜呼！
Joanne's husband, Larry, had been sitting quietly in the room this whole time. He had agreed that a shower was a good idea, but he didn't want to push Joanne on it. And then he seemed happy when she decided to do it. Once she was in, both he and Joanne relaxed a bit. Joanne joked around with Pattie in the shower, and Larry got up to leave and go home to get the house ready for when Joanne got back. They've been married 27 years.
Joanne的丈夫Larry一直静静地坐在房间里。他同意洗澡是个好主意，但他不想强迫Joanne。然后他看到她决定去做时显得很高兴。一旦洗完澡，他和Joanne都放松了一些。Joanne在洗澡时和Pattie开玩笑，Larry起身离开，回家去为Joanne回去做准备。他们已经结婚27年了。
Do you want to give him a grocery list or anything, Joanne?
你想给他开个购物清单之类的吗，Joanne？
[CHUCKLING]
[笑声]
Little honey-do list before you get there?
在你到家前列个小小的“待办事项”清单？
Love you, hon.
爱你，亲爱的。
I love you, too. See you soon.
我也爱你。回头见。
Your tailbone is sore? All right, we'll make sure to get that.
你的尾骨痛吗？好吧，我们一定会处理好的。
There's a note on the Medicare website about hospice, saying, hospice isn't just for cancer. I saw people at Kaplan House with other conditions-- end-stage dementia, congestive heart failure. But mostly I saw cancer. Asa had cancer.
医疗保险网站上有一条关于临终关怀的说明，说临终关怀不仅仅针对癌症。我在Kaplan之家看到了患有其他疾病的人——晚期痴呆症、充血性心力衰竭。但大多数我看到的是癌症。Asa患的就是癌症。
At the Kaplan House, I realized I had questions about the physical part of what had happened with him. I saw other people who had that extreme cancer thinness I learned the medical term-- cachectic. It's from Greek words that mean bad condition. In a few rooms, I saw the same swabs, these little green sponges on the end of a stick, that we used to keep Asa's mouth clean and moist.
在Kaplan之家，我意识到我对发生在他身上的身体部分有疑问。我看到了其他人有那种极端的癌症消瘦，我学到了医学术语——恶病质。它源于希腊语，意味着状况糟糕。在几个房间里，我看到了同样的拭子，那种末端带有绿色小海绵的棍子，我们曾用它来保持Asa的口腔清洁湿润。
The swabs stayed with me because I remember being grateful that they gave us a way-- a small way-- we could care for Asa even after he'd stopped being able to tell us what he wanted. That was the hardest time-- for me, at least-- to hear him groaning and not know what to do or not do. We grilled the nurses about what they thought was going on and what we should do. And at the Kaplan House, I saw that a significant part of the nurses' jobs is trying to figure out what a person might need when they can't communicate anymore.
这些拭子让我印象深刻，因为我记得我很感激它们给了我们一种方式——一种小方式——即使在他已经无法告诉我们他想要什么之后，我们依然能照顾Asa。那是最艰难的时刻——至少对我而言——听到他呻吟却不知道该做什么或不该做什么。我们向护士们盘问她们认为发生了什么以及我们应该做什么。在Kaplan之家，我看到护士工作的重要部分是试图弄清楚一个人在无法沟通时可能需要什么。
Are you having pain? Does something hurt?
你感到疼痛吗？有什么地方痛吗？
[MUMBLING]
[嘟囔声]
Pattie is back in Lori's room, Crystal's mother. It's nighttime. We're into the double part of Pattie's double shift. And Lori is moving around a lot in the bed. It sounds terrible to say, but I felt comforted to see it and to see others at Kaplan House do it, too, because I'd seen it with Asa.
Pattie回到Lori的房间了，就是Crystal的母亲。现在是深夜。我们进入了Pattie双班的后半部分。Lori在床上动得很厉害。说出来听着很可怕，但我感到很安慰，看到她这样，也看到Kaplan之家的其他人也这样做，因为我在Asa身上也见过。
[MUMBLING]
[嘟囔声]
Apparently, it's common toward the end. It's called terminal agitation. Lori's family hasn't slept in 24 hours because Lori was up all night last night, delirious, moving, sometimes trying to get out of bed, even though she's too weak to stand and could easily break a bone if she falls. It's exhausting to deal with and hard to watch.
显然，这在临终时很常见。这被称为临终躁动。Lori的家人已经24小时没睡觉了，因为Lori昨晚整晚都没睡，处于谵妄状态，走动，有时试图起床，尽管她虚弱得站不稳，摔倒很容易骨折。这处理起来很累人，看起来也很难受。
The problem with agitation, as a palliative-care doctor told me, is that it isn't a diagnosis. It's something you see, but the person can be doing it for lots of reasons, each of which calls for a different approach. They could be constipated, anxious, in pain, some combination. A dying person is like a baby that way, except we know even less about a dying person's brain than we do about a baby's.
正如一位姑息治疗医生告诉我的，关于躁动的麻烦在于它不是一种诊断。它是你看到的东西，但此人这样做的原因可能有很多，每一个都需要不同的应对方法。他们可能便秘、焦虑、疼痛或某种组合。濒死的人在这方面就像婴儿，除了我们对濒死之人的大脑知之甚少，甚至不如对婴儿的大脑了解。
Some of the guesses we make are based on what we know from coma patients. But a dying brain is not a comatose brain. It's different. And in terms of what a dying person perceives, someone who's non-responsive, the science of it-- we know almost nothing. The nurses told me they assume that people can hear us right to the end, but no one knows for sure.
我们做的一些猜测是基于我们从昏迷病人那里所知的。但濒死的大脑不是昏迷的大脑。它是不同的。就濒死之人感知到的东西而言，对于一个没有反应的人，关于它的科学——我们几乎一无所知。护士们告诉我，她们假设人们能一直听到我们说话直到最后，但没人能肯定。
[MUMBLING]
[嘟囔声]
Lori's eyes are open, but it's that distant stare like Asa had. She's not seeing what's in front of her. Her mouth is open, and she's squirming in the bed. She was a sign-language interpreter, and sometimes she seems to be signing. But no one in the room knows what she's saying, if anything.
Lori的眼睛睁着，但那是那种像Asa曾有过的那种遥远的凝视。她看不见眼前的东西。她的嘴张着，在床上扭动。她曾是一名手语翻译，有时她似乎在打手势。但房间里没人知道她在说什么，如果有的话。
You want to tell us something.
你想告诉我们什么吗。
Pattie is right up close, talking to Lori, watching her face. It's something I saw the nurses do with Asa, too-- get right up close and talk to him and watch his face, even after he seemed to have stopped responding, because sometimes, suddenly, he would respond, especially to direct questions like--
Pattie靠得很近，和Lori说话，看着她的脸。这也是我在Asa身上看到的护士们做过的事——靠得很近，对他说话，观察他的表情，即使在他似乎停止反应之后，因为有时，突然间，他会有反应，特别是对直接的问题，比如——
Are you having pain?
你感到疼痛吗？
--are you in pain? Lori gives a small shake of her head and says, no.
——你感到疼痛吗？Lori轻轻摇了摇头说，不。
No.
不。
Oh, good. Oh, I'm glad to hear that. Yeah. Do you have to pee?
噢，太好了。噢，听到这个我很高兴。是的。你需要撒尿吗？
[MUMBLING]
[嘟囔声]
I'm thinking of putting a catheter in to help you pee.
我想放一根导尿管来帮你尿尿。
[MUMBLING]
[嘟囔声]
Yeah, I think it's probably bothering her. She hasn't peed. And yeah, I'm going to do that, OK?
是的，我想这可能在困扰她。她还没有排尿。是的，我会那样做的，好吗？
Pattie and Christiana, one of the hospice aides, put in a catheter, and the bag immediately starts filling up. Lori relaxes. The whole family relaxes. Or at least, they're able to give in to their exhaustion. Lori's girlfriend, Karen, finds Pattie in the hall.
Pattie和临终关怀助理Christiana装了一根导尿管，袋子立刻开始填充。Lori放松了。全家人都放松了。或者至少，他们能够屈服于精疲力竭。Lori的女友Karen在走廊里找到了Pattie。
The cancer doctor said that she might-- chances are, she might fall asleep and die in her sleep, because--
癌症医生说她可能——很有可能，她会入睡并在睡梦中去世，因为——
That's what I think.
我也是这么认为的。
--the cancer doctor knew her well, too-- knew she was a toughie.
——癌症医生也很了解她——知道她是个坚强的人。
She is a toughie.
她是位坚强的人。
Yeah.
是的。
I think the catheter is really helping her to settle down.
我觉得导尿管确实在帮助她安定下来。
Good.
太好了。
OK?
好吗？
Yeah, I think I'm going to go home, take a shower--
是的，我想我回家洗个澡——
Good.
好。
--relax as much as I can. And then--
——尽可能放松一下。然后——
Good, good. If I see a major change, I will call you.
好，好。如果我看到重大变化，我会给你打电话的。
OK.
好。
But as I said, sometimes they just sneak away.
但就像我说的，有时他们只是悄悄地走了。
Yeah, I know. I'm not surprised. Yeah.
是的，我知道。我不感到惊讶。是的。
Yeah.
是的。
You know my number.
你知道我的号码。
You feel useless.
你会感到无助。
This is the sister of another patient. She came straight from work to be with him and has been here day and night for two days. I've been talking to her a lot. I know the strain of this waiting, where nothing is happening, and your brain keeps flitting between the giant, existential thing that's going on and the tedious nuts and bolts of just getting through every hour. Every moment seems full of meaning and yet not meaningful at all. It's surreal, and it is crazy-making.
这是另一位病人的姐姐。她下班后直接赶来看他，已经在这里没日没夜待了两天了。我和她聊了很多。我知道这种等待的煎熬，什么都没发生，而你的大脑一直在那种巨大的生存问题和每小时都要熬过去的枯燥琐事之间晃荡。每一刻似乎都充满了意义，却又完全没有意义。这很超现实，而且让人发疯。
How are you doing?
你还好吗？
I'm exhausted. Yeah, I'm exhausted. It's like, what am I doing? I'm just watching him. Like, last night, all's he does is-- I'll tell you what he does. He makes this noise. It's like, [GROANS], but non-stop. So I try to do it with him. Not as loud, just-- I cannot hold it as long as he can. I'm like, this kid is not even going to stop to take a breath. Me? I'm like, [PANTS]. It's exhausting, and he can do it.
我精疲力竭。是的，我精疲力竭。就像，我在干什么？我只是看着他。比如，昨晚，他所做的只有——我告诉你他做了什么。他发出这种声音。就像，[呻吟]，但没完没了。所以我试着跟他一起做。声音没那么大，只是——我无法坚持像他那么久。我想，这个孩子甚至都不停下来喘口气。我？就像，[喘气]。这很累人，而他却能做到。
You must really think I'm nuts. There's nothing else to do, is all. I don't know what I want to do. It's not like he can--
你肯定觉得我疯了。什么也做不了，就是这样。我不知道我想做什么。他也不是能——
I'm so sorry.
我很抱歉。
Oh, no, don't be sorry. You know what? I'm just sitting here for like-- just sitting. You can't do anything. I'm tired of praying to God. Really, I'm tired. But I told him I'd stay with him. And I don't want to-- even if he doesn't know I'm here or not, I know I'm here.
噢，不，别抱歉。你知道吗？我只是坐在这里——就是坐着。你什么也做不了。我厌倦了向神祈祷。真的，我厌倦了。但我告诉过他我会陪着他。我不想要——即使他不知道我是否在这里，但我知道我在这里。
I never knew what anyone was going to say at the Kaplan House. Listening to family members in rooms and in the halls, I got the feeling that their brains were full to the brim with what was happening, and asking them any question tipped all their thoughts out in a rush.
我在Kaplan之家从未知道任何人会说什么。听着房间里和走廊里家属的谈话，我感觉他们的大脑里充满了正在发生的事情，而向他们提任何问题都会让他们的思绪一涌而出。
Some people told me the whole story of their family member's diagnosis and treatment up to five minutes ago. I heard one of the doctors say to an 84-year-old woman who was sitting with her dying husband, you know him better than we do. Does he look comfortable to you? The woman responded by telling the entire story of their relationship, starting with, we met when I was 13.
有些人告诉了我他们家人从确诊到治疗的整个故事，直到五分钟前。我听到一位医生对一位坐在濒死丈夫身边的84岁老妇人说，你比我们更了解他。你觉得他看起来舒服吗？那位老妇人回答说，讲述了他们关系的全部故事，从“我们13岁时相遇”开始。
The staff has a name for that kind of answer. It's called life review. They say it happens a lot. And I heard life reviews that were a lot darker than that one. Not every death is the end of a well-lived life. But all the stories seem to be trying to tackle the same huge question. How did we get here?
工作人员对那种回答有个名称。它被称为“生命回顾”。他们说这种情况经常发生。我听到的生命回顾比那一个要黑暗得多。并非每一次死亡都是人生圆满的终点。但所有的故事似乎都在试图解决同一个巨大的问题。我们是怎么到这里的？
Grief is one thing, but watching somebody die is a whole 'nother thing.
悲伤是一回事，但目睹某人死亡则是完全另一回事。
Pattie again.
又是Pattie。
You know, not everybody can sit beside a dying person and hold their hand. And I think sometimes it's too much. Nobody wants their loved ones to be alone. I get that. But you could wait here for days and days, and when you go to take that one shower is when the person might die.
你知道，并不是每个人都能坐在濒死的人旁边握住他们的手。我觉得有时这太多了。没人希望他们的亲人孤单。我明白。但你可以在这里等上好几天，而当你去洗个澡时，那个人可能就去世了。
And sometimes people I've talked to say it's common that the person will die--
有时我谈过的人说很常见，那个人会——
Alone.
独自死去。
Well, it's almost like they're waiting for everyone to go away.
嗯，这几乎就像他们在等每个人都离开。
Right, right.
对，对。
Is that what you've found?
你也是这么发现的吗？
We see that over and over and over again. When I first started working there, I'm like, this is a bit of mumbo-jumbo. [LAUGHS] And it just seemed like, come on. Now I'm repeating the same stuff that I heard people say when I first got there, because I've seen it.
我们反复看到这种情况。当我刚开始在那里工作时，我想，这有点像胡言乱语。[笑声] 这看起来就像，得了吧。现在我重复着我刚到那里时听到别人说的话，因为我已经亲眼见到了。
You mean that people die when either everyone leaves the room, or their spouse or their child or whoever has been there for a long time-- they die after that person leaves the room.
你是说当每个人都离开房间时，或者他们的配偶或孩子或其他陪伴了很长时间的人——他们在那个人离开房间后去世。
Yeah, or they're comatose, and the loved ones keep saying, he's waiting for his brother to get here on Saturday. They're coming from Florida on Saturday. And I'm, inside, rolling my eyes, thinking, it's Tuesday. He's going to die on Wednesday or Thursday. He's not going to be here on Saturday for when his brother arrives from Florida. And then the brother arrives at Logan, shows up at the Kaplan House at 12:30, and the patient dies at 1:00. And they say to me, I told you. He just needed Billy to come from Florida. And it's like, what?
是的，或者他们处于昏迷状态，亲人们一直在说，他在等他哥哥周六赶到。他们周六从佛罗里达赶来。而我，在心里翻着白眼，心想，今天是周二。他会在周三或周四去世。他不会等到周六他哥哥从佛罗里达赶来时还在。然后他哥哥到达洛根机场，12:30出现在Kaplan之家，病人在1:00去世。他们对我说，我告诉过你吧。他只是需要Billy从佛罗里达赶来。这就好比，什么？
Talking to people about whoever they were visiting at the Kaplan House always brought up other, earlier losses. Always. One woman who was sitting with her mother told me about how her husband had died suddenly eight years earlier, making her a widow at age 51. A woman whose younger sister was dying said she lost both parents before age 13.
和人们谈论他们在Kaplan之家探望的人总是会引发其他更早的失落。总是这样。一位陪伴母亲的女士告诉我她的丈夫八年前突然去世，使她在51岁时就成了寡妇。一位妹妹正濒死的女士说她在13岁之前就失去了双亲。
A woman visiting her brother told me about how his daughter had died years ago at only two years old. The woman said her brother was so angry about his daughter's death that he said to her, his sister, why couldn't it have been one of your effing daughters? You've got two.
一位探望兄弟的女士告诉我他的女儿几年前在只有两岁时就去世了。那位女士说她的兄弟对女儿的死亡非常愤怒，以至于他对他的姐姐说，为什么不能是你他妈的女儿之一呢？你有两个。
It was like a map. This death related to that death over there, linked to this living person here, a hidden geography shaping all of our lives.
这就像一张地图。这个死亡关联着那个那边的死亡，与这个活着的某人相连，一个隐藏的地理结构塑造了我们所有人的生活。
After I'd been at the Kaplan House for several days, I ran into Larry, the husband of Joanne, the woman Pattie coaxed into getting a shower before going home. Larry was sitting alone in the main common area. I knew it couldn't be good that Joanne was back so soon.
我在Kaplan之家待了几天后，遇见了Larry，Joanne的丈夫，就是Pattie在回家前哄她去洗澡的那位女士。Larry独自坐在主要公共区域。我知道Joanne这么快回来肯定不是好事。
Well, the doctor was in earlier. Were you there when the doctor said she thought she had like a week or so left?
嗯，医生早些时候来过。你当时在吗，当医生说她觉得她大概还有一周左右的时间？
I wasn't there.
我不在那儿。
Yeah. And I figured she was closing in on it, because of the way I've watched her deteriorate. But when you hear somebody who's used to dealing with this for a living tell you that they think that's what's left, it hits home.
是的。我猜她快到头了，因为我看着她不断恶化。但当你听到一个靠处理这种事情谋生的人告诉你他们认为这就是剩下的时间时，它触动了内心。
I'm so sorry, Larry.
我很遗憾，Larry。
[SIGHS] It's a bitter pill to swallow, but that's life. It goes on no matter what. [SIGHS]
[叹气] 这是一粒苦药，但这就是生活。无论如何它都会继续。[叹气]
One of the many ways I've been a smug idiot in my life was by disparaging the use of euphemisms for death and dying. I thought it was weak. Who would do that? By the time Asa was at the end, I had barely been able to utter the words "death" or "dying" for several months. I felt like the thing itself was only manageable if I didn't invoke it.
我一生中做自以为是的白痴的诸多方式之一，就是贬低对死亡和濒死使用委婉语。我曾经认为那很软弱。谁会那么做呢？当Asa走到尽头时，我已经几个月几乎无法吐出“死亡”或“濒死”这两个词了。我感觉如果不提到它，事情本身就是可控的。
Pattie told me that one of her strategies for protecting herself at work is never to imagine herself in the place of the dying person or their family members. She tries not to picture her husband or her kids. I remember trying and failing at that.
Pattie告诉我，她在工作中保护自己的策略之一是从不将自己置于濒死之人或其家属的位置。她尽量不去想象自己的丈夫或孩子。我记得自己尝试并失败了。
I think part of my clumsiness around Asa and my mother was my barely-suppressed terror at the thought of my own husband dying. I pictured myself in my mother's place all the time. Every morning before going to her apartment, I pulled out a piece of paper, and I had to read the words on it out loud in order to make it out the door. "Your husband isn't dying. This is not about you. Your mother needs you. Go to her apartment now." It was my own little serenity prayer. God grant me the wisdom to know the difference between my fear and her reality.
我认为我在Asa和我母亲身边的笨拙，部分原因是我对自己丈夫即将离世这一想法近乎无法抑制的恐惧。我一直把自己想象成母亲的位置。每天早上在去她公寓之前，我会拿出一张纸，大声读出上面的话，以便能走出家门。“你的丈夫没有死去。这与你无关。你需要母亲。现在就去她公寓。”那是我自己的小“宁静祷文”。上帝赐予我智慧，让我分辨出我的恐惧和她的现实之间的区别。
When I heard a woman at the Kaplan House say to her husband, who was dying of colon cancer, something like, we had a really good run until the last few months, didn't we, baby? I had to turn away to go look at a lamp in the corner.
当听到Kaplan之家的一位女士对她因结肠癌濒死的丈夫说，像“在那最后几个月之前我们过得很好，不是吗，宝贝？”之类的话时，我不得不转过身去看角落里的一盏灯。
But I think death makes narcissists of us all at one point or another, even the pros. I was walking with a nurse named Kim. She worked in critical care for two-plus decades before changing over to hospice. We had just left one woman's room and were heading down the hall when Kim said, shaking her head--
但我认为死亡在某个阶段会让我们所有人都成为自恋者，甚至是专业人士。我正和一位叫Kim的护士一起走。她在重症监护室工作了二十多年才转到临终关怀。我们刚离开一位女士的房间，正走在走廊里时，Kim摇着头说——
She's 51. I'm 52.
她51岁。我52岁。
Kim, and everyone else, said these are the cases that can be hardest to defend against-- the ones where you can't not picture yourself when you look at them. She had another just last week.
Kim，还有其他人，说这些是最难防御的病例——那些当你看着他们时无法不想象到自己的病例。她上周刚有一个。
There was one woman I had my age. And she had two boys that were my age--
有一个和我年龄一样的女士。她有两个和我年龄一样的儿子——
Your sons' ages.
和你儿子的年龄一样。
My sons' ages. And the boys were very attentive. They stayed with her and just laid beside her. And it was just really-- it hit me on the way home. You think, oh my gosh, this could be me.
我儿子的年龄。孩子们非常体贴。他们待在她身边，只是躺在她旁边。真的非常——我在回家的路上深受触动。你会想，噢天哪，这可能是我。
It was the same age as me, I remember.
记得和我年龄一样大。
This is Juliet, one of the CNAs, Certified Nursing Assistants. She's studying to be a nurse, and she remembered the first time she had a patient her own age.
这位是Juliet，认证护理助理（CNA）之一。她正在学习成为一名护士，她记得第一次有和她自己年龄一样的病人。
At that time, I had just turned 39. And I'm like, oh my god. I actually said, oh my god. That's my age. Oh my god. That's me. That's me. That's me.
那时候，我刚满39岁。我心想，噢我的天。我真的说了，噢我的天。那是我这个年纪。噢我的天。那就是我。那就是我。那就是我。
Sometimes they see patients their children's ages. This is Jackie, another nurse.
有时他们看到病人是他们孩子那么大。这是Jackie，另一位护士。
We had a nine-year-old boy that was here. And my daughter, Sarah, was nine years old at the time. And I remember climbing in her bed when I went home, and I just fell asleep in her bed. And she was so mad at me, [LAUGHS] because I'm breathing on her and stealing her covers. And she was so mad. And I remember just waking up and thinking that was the funniest thing in the world-- that she was mad. But I needed to do that when I came home that night. I needed to know, my nine-year-old is OK.
我们这里曾有一个9岁的男孩。我女儿Sarah那时正好9岁。我记得回家时爬上她的床，我就在她的床上睡着了。她对我非常生气，[笑声]，因为我在她身边呼吸并抢她的被子。她非常生气。我记得醒来时心想这是世界上最有趣的事情——她竟然在生气。但我那天晚上回家时需要那样做。我需要知道，我9岁的女儿很好。
Jackie also told me, while I was following her around, throwing out questions--
Jackie也告诉我，当我跟在她身后，抛出一堆问题时——
Last year, I had my kidney removed because I had a big tumor in it. So--
去年，我切除了肾脏，因为里面长了一个大肿瘤。所以——
Oh my god.
噢我的天。
--all I could think of was, oh, shit, I'm going to end up at work. [LAUGHS] But if I'm to be anywhere, that's where I wanted to be. And when one of our docs-- Dr. Warren came to see me in the hospital. And I thought, this is it. I'm dying. The hospice doc just walked in the door.
——我能想到的只有，该死，我最后得来上班了。[笑声] 但如果我非得待在某个地方，那就是我想待的地方。当我们的医生之一——Warren医生来看我时，在医院里。我想，这就是了。我要死了。临终关怀医生就这么走进了门。
And it does happen. A nurse named Rosemary, who's been there for a long time, told me about one of the other longtime nurses, Kathleen.
而且它确实发生了。一位名叫Rosemary的护士，在那里待了很长时间，告诉我另一位资深护士Kathleen的事。
Went out on medical leave to have her bunions fixed and was diagnosed with ovarian cancer, and just had a very rough go of it. Nothing worked. Every treatment, she had reactions to. And finally, it was time for Kathleen to come to the Kaplan House. And she was determined that she was not going to come in on a stretcher like the other patients, because she was a nurse. So she walked down the hall and greeted everybody on her way down.
请假去治脚外翻，却被诊断出患有卵巢癌，经历非常痛苦。什么都没用。每次治疗她都有反应。最后，轮到Kathleen来Kaplan之家了。她很坚定，她不像其他病人那样坐担架进来，因为她是个护士。所以她沿着走廊走进来，在路上向每个人打招呼。
But it was really hard for us to take care of one of our own, because I think we think, well, we're hospice nurses, so we don't get sick. And the first night, she came in, and I had her as a patient. And I came out to my med cart, and there was a note. "Dear Rosemary, could I please have a milligram of Dilaudid for 8 out of 10 pain? I know you're going to think I should have 2 milligrams, but I only want 1 milligram. No hurry. Take care of the patients first. And one face cloth and one towel when you get a chance." And that was just Kathleen.
但我们照顾自己人真的很困难，因为我觉得我们认为，嗯，我们是临终关怀护士，所以我们不会生病。第一天晚上，她住进来，我是她的护士。我出来到我的药品车边，那里有一张纸条。“亲爱的Rosemary，能给我一毫克Dilaudid以缓解8分疼痛吗？我知道你会觉得我应该要2毫克，但我只需要1毫克。不着急。先照顾其他病人。有空时给我一条洗脸巾和一条毛巾。”这就是Kathleen。
Death and illness, who's here and who's not, how we live with this hanging over us-- these are the conversations I'd been waiting years to have. Before I left, I got to ask Pattie what it's like to talk with her patients so directly the way that I was never able to do with Asa.
死亡和疾病，谁在这里，谁不在了，我们如何带着这种悬而未决的感觉生活——这些是我等了多年想谈的话题。离开之前，我有机会问Pattie，像我从未能和Asa那样直截了当地与病人谈话是什么感觉。
Patients all the time ask you, is this it? Am I dying? And the first thing I usually do is say, well, you might know better than me. Do you think you're dying? And usually, if it's a dying person, they say yes.
病人总是问你，这就是终点了吗？我要死了吗？我通常做的第一件事是说，嗯，你可能比我更清楚。你觉得你要死了吗？通常，如果是濒死的人，他们会说是。
And I'll say, are you nervous? Are you anxious? What are you afraid of? And if they say, I'm afraid I'm going to have pain, we'll just talk about it and say, well, I've got this, this, and this to give you if you have pain. So if you feel a little bit of pain, I want you to tell me. And we'll head off a little problem rather than a big problem.
然后我会说，你紧张吗？你焦虑吗？你怕什么？如果他们说，我怕我会痛，我们就会讨论一下，说，嗯，如果你痛的话，我有这个、这个、这个可以给你。所以如果你感到一点疼痛，我希望你告诉我。我们会把小问题解决掉，而不是让它变成大问题。
And they'll say, well, I'm afraid I'll feel like I won't be able to breathe. Then we talk about that, about the medications I'll give them. And all they have to do is tell me they're short of breath, and they get the medicine. They're afraid they'll be alone. And I'll say, well, let's talk to your family about that, or I'll be here. I'll be checking on you.
他们会说，嗯，我怕我会觉得无法呼吸。然后我们谈论那个，谈论我会给他们的药物。他们所要做的就是告诉我他们呼吸困难，然后他们就会得到药物。他们怕会孤单。我会说，嗯，我们和你的家人谈谈那个，或者我会在这里。我会来看看你的。
I asked Pattie if anyone at the end of that list says, well, I'm just afraid of dying. I fear death. She said yes. And she listens if they want to talk about it, offers to bring in the chaplain or the social worker. What else is there? That might be the biggest thing that she and the other nurses know that we don't. They know the limits of what they can do.
我问Pattie，如果那个清单最后有人说，嗯，我只是怕死。我惧怕死亡。她说是的。如果他们想谈谈，她会倾听，提议请牧师或社工来。还能有什么呢？这可能是她和其他护士知道而我们不知道的最重要的事情。她们知道自己能做的事情的极限。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show.
Nancy Updike是我们节目的制片人之一。
Coming up, since the federal government can no longer count on cartoon characters to bring in our tax dollars as they once did, what is left for them? My answer is in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，由于联邦政府不能再指望卡通人物像过去那样为我们带来税收，他们还剩下什么？一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时，我会给出我的答案。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme. Today's program-- death and taxes, stories about the inevitable, stories where people who know about these things share their inside knowledge with us. In Act 1, we heard all about death. We have now arrived at Act 2, which is about taxes.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。当然，每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题。今天的节目——死亡与税收，关于不可避免之事的报道，在这些故事中，了解这些事情的人与我们分享了他们的内部知识。在第一幕中，我们听到了关于死亡的一切。现在我们到达了第二幕，关于税收。
I think most of us think of taxes as inevitable like death. But in fact, while we all die, we do not all pay our taxes. According to the most recent statistics, the IRS only successfully collects 85% of the money that all of us owe, which is a lot of money. They miss $385 billion out of $2.6 trillion they should be collecting. Though when you think about it, what is amazing is how many of us actually do pay. There are entire countries where it seems like most people are cheating. Greece, I'm looking at you.
我认为我们大多数人认为税收像死亡一样不可避免。但事实上，虽然我们都会死，但并非我们所有人都纳税。根据最新统计，国税局（IRS）只能成功收取我们所有人都欠的钱的85%，这可是一大笔钱。在他们本应收取的2.6万亿美元中，他们漏掉了3850亿美元。虽然当你仔细想想，令人惊讶的是我们中有多少人确实纳税了。有些整个国家似乎大部分人都在作弊。希腊，我是在说你。
Here, we pay up, most of us, because of some combination of, A, we think we don't have a choice-- though if you'd bother to look into it, you would learn that the IRS does not have that many people checking on us-- and B, we think it's the right thing to do. NPR's David Kestenbaum has this story about how we got here and about one former IRS special agent trying, even in retirement, to help Uncle Sam in this quest.
在这里，我们付钱，我们大多数人，因为某种组合，A，我们认为我们别无选择——尽管如果你费心查一下，你会发现国税局并没有那么多人在查我们——以及B，我们认为这是正确的事。NPR的David Kestenbaum带来了这篇关于我们是如何走到这一步，以及一位前国税局特工即使在退休后，仍试图在这一任务中帮助山姆大叔的故事。
The first year the government tried to collect an income tax from broad swaths of Americans was during World War II. And really, it was unclear how well it was going to work. One poll showed that one third to one half of people weren't sure what they were supposed to do.
政府试图从广大美国人那里征收所得税的第一年是在二战期间。坦率地说，大家并不清楚这会运作得如何。一项民意调查显示，三分之一到一半的人不确定他们应该做什么。
And the government faced this choice. There were basically two options. The government could play tough, say this is the law. You have to pay. It could scare people. Or it could try to inspire people to pay their taxes.
政府面临这个选择。基本上有两种选择。政府可以表现强硬，说这是法律。你必须付钱。它可以吓唬人们。或者它可以尝试激励人们纳税。
We went with inspire. We chose a spokesperson who could sell the income tax, someone with credibility, someone who was instantly recognizable and easy to understand.
我们选择了激励。我们选择了一位可以推销所得税的发言人，一个有公信力的人，一个立刻就能被识别且容易理解的人。
That is not right!
那是不对的！
We went with Donald Duck. This is a short film by Disney from 1942, commissioned by the government. In it, Donald Duck is marching around his house patriotically, listening to the radio, and talking back to it.
我们选择了唐老鸭。这是一部1942年由迪斯尼拍摄的短片，由政府委托。在片中，唐老鸭爱国地在他房子周围行军，听着广播，并对它说话。
Your country needs you.
你的国家需要你。
OK!
好！
Donald Duck runs and gets a gun and a sword and an axe and boxing gloves.
唐老鸭跑去拿枪、剑、斧头和拳击手套。
Are you a patriotic American--
你是一个爱国的美国人——
Yes, sir!
是的，长官！
--eager to do your part?
——渴望尽你的一份力量吗？
Yes, sir!
是的，长官！
Then there's something important you can do.
那么有一件重要的事情你可以做。
Oh, boy. Oh, boy. Oh, boy. I'll do it.
噢，天哪。噢，天哪。噢，天哪。我会做的。
You won't get a medal for doing it.
你做这件事不会得到奖牌。
Oh, that's all right.
噢，那没关系。
It may mean a sacrifice on your part.
这可能意味着你做出一点牺牲。
I'll do it anyway.
我还是会做的。
But it will be a vital help to your country in this hour of need.
但这对你的国家在危难时刻将是极大的帮助。
I'll do anything! Anything!
我什么都愿意做！什么都愿意！
Shall I tell you what it is?
我能告诉你那是什么吗？
Yes! What is it? Tell me!
是的！那是什么？告诉我！
Shall I?
能吗？
Tell me what it is!
告诉我那是什么！
Your income tax.
你的所得税。
Income tax?
所得税？
[POP]
[砰]
Yes, your income tax.
是的，你的所得税。
Doggone income tax.
该死的所得税。
They walk him through filing his whole tax return.
他们引导他填写了完整的报税表。
You made less than $3,000 last year?
你去年收入不到3000美元？
Yes, sir!
是的，长官！
Well, then you can use the new simplified form.
好吧，那么你可以使用新的简化表格。
Donald Duck writes in occupation-- actor. Income-- $2,501. He lists his dependents, three-- Huey, Dewey, and Louie.
唐老鸭在职业栏填写——演员。收入——2501美元。他列出了他的受抚养人，三个——Huey、Dewey和Louie。
Huey, Dewey, and Louie.
Huey、Dewey和Louie。
They have him look up how much he owes in the tax tables.
他们让他查阅税表看看他欠多少钱。
Oh, I owe just about--
噢，我欠的大约——
This film was nominated for an Academy Award. And remarkably, this approach worked. Millions of Americans became responsible income taxpayers for the first time. Of course, when you're fighting the Nazis and you've got Donald Duck making the pitch, it's an easy sell. During the war, almost 90% of Americans polled said their taxes were fair. After the war, that plunged to around 60%.
这部影片获得了奥斯卡提名。值得注意的是，这种方法有效了。数百万美国人第一次成了负责任的所得税纳税人。当然，当你正在与纳粹作战，而且有唐老鸭在推销时，这很容易卖出去。战争期间，几乎90%受访的美国人认为他们的税收是公平的。战后，这一数字下降到了约60%。
These days, some of us aren't so convinced of our duty. A recent survey by the IRS showed something like 1 in 10 people felt it was OK to cheat a little here and there or as much as possible on their taxes.
这些天，我们中有些人对我们的义务不太确信。国税局最近的一项调查显示，大约十分之一的人觉得在税收上这里那里作弊一点，或尽可能多作弊一点是可以接受的。
This is the taxpaying world that Al Drucker discovered when he started working for the IRS in 1981. He'd just graduated from John Jay College of Criminal Justice, and he was hoping to land a job at the FBI, or maybe the DEA, chasing drug traffickers. But the way things worked is, you just took this general aptitude test, and you waited to see who called. And the call he got was from the IRS.
这就是Al Drucker在1981年开始为国税局工作时发现的纳税世界。他刚从John Jay刑事司法学院毕业，他希望能得到一份FBI的工作，或者也许是缉毒局（DEA），去追捕毒贩。但当时的工作方式是，你只需参加这个通用能力倾向测试，然后等待看谁会打来电话。他接到的电话是来自国税局的。
Was it my peak choice? No. If I was in that recruiting forum and there were 20 booths, and one was DEA, and one was IRS, I'd probably go to the IRS last.
那是我的首选吗？不是。如果我在那个招聘论坛，有20个展位，一个是DEA，一个是IRS，我可能会最后才去IRS。
Al didn't really even know the IRS hired law-enforcement people. But he took the job. They trained him to shoot a gun. They taught him special driving pursuit skills. And they gave him an impressive-looking badge that said Special Agent Number 4158, with the seal of the US Treasury on it. And he got to work.
Al甚至不知道国税局还招募执法人员。但他接受了工作。他们训练他开枪。他们教他特殊的驾驶追捕技能。他们给了他一个看起来令人印象深刻的徽章，上面写着特工编号4158，带着美国财政部的印章。于是他开始工作。
One of Al's first cases came from a tip. It was a tip about a guy who ran a pharmacy in New Jersey. Someone had told the IRS, hey, you should check this guy out. I'm pretty sure he's cheating on his taxes. So Al, with a colleague, went to the pharmacy.
Al最早的案件之一来自举报。关于一个在新泽西州经营药店的家伙的举报。有人告诉国税局，嘿，你们应该查查这家伙。我很确定他在报税上作弊。所以Al和一位同事去了那家药店。
And it was an old-fashioned-type pharmacy, a regular prescription-bearing pharmacy that would sell newspapers and gum and any of the stationery and cards, greeting cards and things of this nature.
那是一家老式药店，一家正规的售卖处方药的药店，还卖报纸、口香糖、文具、贺卡以及这类东西。
Even in retirement, Al still speaks like a cop-- things of this nature, the suspect, the informant. Anyway, Al and his partner walk into the pharmacy, and the pharmacist is there. And they get the strangest reception.
即使在退休后，Al说话依然像个警察——这类东西、嫌疑人、线人。总之，Al和他的搭档走进药店，药剂师在那里。他们受到了最奇怪的接待。
Believe it or not, he looked at my partner and myself. And he looked at us, and he said, you guys are with the IRS, aren't you? As if he was expecting a visit.
信不信由你，他看着我和我的搭档。他看着我们说，你们是国税局的，对吧？好像他预料到了会有访问。
Which, of course, he might have been. Someone, after all, had ratted him out. That was why Al was looking into this guy. And it was probably someone the pharmacist knew pretty well.
这当然是可能的。毕竟，有人举报了他。这就是Al调查这个家伙的原因。而且这很可能是药剂师非常熟悉的人。
It may be an employee. Sometimes an employee will brag about, when they're fired, turning the boss in, et cetera, et cetera.
可能是员工。有时员工被解雇时会吹嘘自己把老板举报了，等等。
The insider tip. It was a powerful thing. Al looked into the pharmacist's bank records and pretty quickly found something fishy. The guy didn't seem to be depositing any cash. All the money came from checks and credit cards. And clearly, people had been buying gum and newspapers and greeting cards with cash. Where was all the cash going?
内部告密。这是一件有力的事。Al查看了药剂师的银行记录，很快发现了一些可疑之处。这家伙似乎没有存任何现金。所有的钱都来自支票和信用卡。显然，人们一直用现金购买口香糖、报纸和贺卡。现金都去哪儿了？
We were able to establish that there was another secret bank account where the cash was going.
我们成功证实了还有一个秘密银行账户，现金都流向了那里。
Where was the secret bank account?
秘密银行账户在哪里？
Just a different bank than he typically used.
只是比他常用的那家银行不同的另一家。
Oh, it wasn't--
噢，它不是——
No, it wasn't offshore. It wasn't-- no, it--
不，不是离岸的。不是——不，它——
It was around the corner.
就在街角。
It was a neighboring town, and it was a different bank than he typically would use.
它是隔壁镇，而且和通常用的银行不同。
Was it in his real name?
是用他的真实名字吗？
It was in his real name.
是用他的真实名字。
[LAUGHS] It's just amazing how simple it is. Basically, his secret bank account was a bank account in his name, one town over. And when he got paid in cash at the pharmacy, he just deposited it there and never declared it.
[笑声]这很简单，真让人吃惊。基本上，他的秘密银行账户就是用他的名字开的，就在隔壁镇的银行。当他在药店收到现金付款时，他就存进那里，从来没申报过。
There's no question. I think a lot of times, it's not nearly as complex as you might think.
毫无疑问。我想很多时候，情况并不像你想象的那么复杂。
A lot of cases are like that, he says. The fraud is right there once you start looking. But you need a reason to start looking. In this case, it was the tip that gave him that reason.
很多案子都是那样的，他说。一旦你开始寻找，欺诈行为就在那里。但你需要一个开始寻找的理由。在这个案子里，举报给了他这个理由。
Tip, of course, is a nice word for it. Ratting out is another. But this notion that good ideas could come from people telling on each other-- it stuck with Al. So a couple years ago, when he retired from the IRS, he set up a business built around this idea, that people could help the government do its job collecting taxes by volunteering information. And here, for once, he did not give it a cop-speak name.
“举报”，当然，是一个好听的词。告密是另一个词。但这种好点子可以来自人们互相检举的想法——它深深吸引了Al。所以几年前，当他从国税局退休时，他创办了一家围绕这个想法的公司，即人们可以通过志愿提供信息来帮助政府完成征税工作。在这里，他难得一次没有给它起个警察味的名字。
TaxSqueal.com.
TaxSqueal.com（报税告密网）。
It's not subtle. You went straight to squeal.
这不含蓄。你直接用了“告密”（squeal）。
Those are the two words that best connote what I was trying to say, which is taxes and squealing. It could have been tax rat. And, well, we experimented plenty with the tax rat, believe me.
这是最能表达我想说的两个词，即税收和告密。本可以是“税收老鼠”（tax rat）。嗯，相信我，我们确实尝试过“税收老鼠”。
I suppose tax rat, you could have had a rat on the site. Tax squeal, you could have a pig.
我想“税收老鼠”，你本可以在网站上放一只老鼠。“税收告密”，你可以放一头猪。
Well, if I could be honest, the name was taken.
嗯，如果我能诚实地说，这个名字已经被占用了。
The IRS does have a way you can rat or squeal on other people. But like all things IRS, it's a pain.
国税局确实有一种你可以举报或告密他人的方法。但像国税局的所有事情一样，那很麻烦。
Welcome to the Internal Revenue Service Tax Fraud Referral Hotline.
欢迎拨打国税局税务欺诈转介热线。
There's a hotline. But if you call, you get this.
有热线。但如果你拨打，你会得到这个。
You can report tax fraud and abuse by completing Form 3949-A or by sending us a letter.
您可以通过填写3949-A表格或给我们寄信来举报税务欺诈和滥用行为。
Of course there's a form. You have to print it out, fill it out, and actually put it in an envelope and mail it to the IRS in Fresno. TaxSqueal.com, Al says, removes the hassle and provides an extra layer of anonymity. You just go to the website, type in some answers-- basically, who are you squealing on, where does the person live, what did they do? And that's it. Al will file the form for you for free.
当然有表格。你必须打印出来，填好，还要真的放进信封寄给弗雷斯诺的国税局。Al说，TaxSqueal.com消除了麻烦，并提供了一层额外的匿名保护。你只需访问网站，输入一些答案——基本上，你举报的是谁，那个人住在哪里，他们做了什么？就这样。Al会免费帮你提交表格。
Al works out of the back of a store his wife runs in a New Jersey strip mall. The store is a little hard to describe. One side, literally one side of it, is devoted to sports memorabilia-- jerseys, photos, baseball cards. The other side is window treatments--
Al在他的妻子经营的一家商店的后面工作，位于新泽西的一个购物广场。那家商店有点难描述。一侧，真的是一侧，专门卖体育纪念品——球衣、照片、棒球卡。另一侧是窗饰——
You have a blind that goes up, a blind that goes down, and certainly a blind that tilts.
你有向上拉的百叶窗，向下拉的百叶窗，当然还有倾斜的百叶窗。
--making this, I think, the only store in America where you can buy baseball cards and window shades and squeal on your neighbor. Al works at a desk in back with his old badge, now preserved in a Lucite block, and some squeals he's printed out. When enough of them pile up, he mails them to the IRS.
——这使它成为我认为美国唯一一家你可以买到棒球卡和百叶窗，并举报你的邻居的商店。Al在他的后办公桌工作，桌上放着他旧的徽章（现在封在透明塑料块里）和一些他打印出来的举报信。当积累到一定数量时，他会把它们寄给国税局。
Al says the IRS-- despite what you might think, it's not all powerful. When he worked there, the IRS had only around 3,000 field agents doing criminal investigations. They are massively outmatched. So the IRS faces this fundamental problem. How do you find the cheaters?
Al说国税局——尽管你可能认为它无所不能，其实不然。当他在那里工作时，国税局只有大约3000名外勤特工进行刑事调查。他们人数上极其处于劣势。所以国税局面临这个根本问题。你如何找到作弊者？
Al's answer, rat them out-- it may sound unpleasant. But it turns out this is one of the oldest tricks we've got. During the Civil War, we had an income tax on the rich for a while. And the government made it so that you could see exactly how much everyone was paying. The idea was that neighbors could rat out the guy next door if he lived on a big estate and didn't seem to be paying much. Squealing was the original form of tax enforcement.
Al的回答，检举他们——这可能听起来令人不快。但事实证明这是我们最古老的技巧之一。内战期间，我们曾有一段时间对富人征收所得税。政府甚至让你能精确看到每个人付了多少钱。想法是，如果隔壁邻居住在豪宅里却似乎没交多少税，邻居们就可以举报他。检举是税务执法的最初形式。
The IRS today has a whistleblower program where they reward people for turning in big fish. Last year, the program paid out $53 million in awards. For smaller squeals, you can print out that form, fill it out, and mail it in. Or there's TaxSqueal.com.
国税局今天有一个吹哨人计划，奖励那些揭发大鱼的人。去年，该计划发放了5300万美元奖金。对于较小的举报，你可以打印出那份表格，填好并寄出。或者有TaxSqueal.com。
This goes. Let's see what's come in recently.
这是寄出的。看看最近收到了什么。
Al reads through some of the stuff he's gotten through his website. There's someone squealing on jai alai gamblers in Florida. There's a retired sheriff ratting out a hair salon. There's one angry one in all caps, and a woman saying her ex-husband is claiming the kids as dependents when she's supposed to be. Actually, Al says there are a lot of exes-- ex-wives, ex-friends, ex-employees.
Al读着他通过网站收到的一些东西。有人在举报佛罗里达的Jai Alai赌徒。有一位退休治安官在举报一家美发沙龙。全是大写的愤怒举报，还有一位女士说她前夫正在把孩子作为受抚养人申报，而本应是她申报。事实上，Al说有很多前任——前妻、前朋友、前员工。
Dr. So-and-so had a dental office installed in the farm in Ohio and would routinely work on Amish and Mennonite patients on the weekends and off days. And those patients paid fully in cash. He would then not include those transactions as part of the regular business income. He would also trade and barter for services and not share those with his staff, who was paid on commission.
某某牙医在俄亥俄州的农场安装了一间牙医诊室，经常在周末和休息日为阿米什和门诺派病人看牙。而那些病人全用现金支付。他随后不会将那些交易作为常规业务收入的一部分包括进去。他还进行服务易货交易，也不与按佣金支付的员工分享。
Al doesn't check the validity of these allegations. He doesn't look into them at all. He just prints them out and mails them in. But if you want to pay just $2, Al does offer one extra service. For $2, Al will mail a little postcard to the person you've squealed on. Postcard is yellow with big black letters that read, you've been squealed on, exclamation point. On the back is a legal disclaimer saying, Tax Squeal is not a government entity, and explaining the Tax Squeal mission. He shows one to me and producer Chana Joffe-Walt.
Al不检查这些指控的有效性。他根本不调查。他只是打印出来并寄过去。但如果你想只付2美元，Al确实提供了一项额外服务。2美元，Al会给被你举报的人寄一张小明信片。明信片是黄色的，上面有黑色大字写着，“你已经被举报了”，后面带着感叹号。背面是法律免责声明，说明税务告密网不是政府机构，并解释了税务告密网的使命。他把其中一张展示给我和制片人Chana Joffe-Walt看。
We have these nifty little postcards that say, you've been squealed on. And this will get mailed out.
我们有这些漂亮的小明信片，上面写着“你已经被举报了”。这会被寄出去。
It's like a little extra "screw you."
就像一点额外的“去死吧”。
[SIGH] Yes, it is. But it gives people another opportunity to get this information forward.
[叹气] 是的，确实是。但它给了人们另一个机会将这些信息向前推进。
And it's a way to really scare somebody who's not paying their taxes.
这是一种恐吓那些不纳税的人的方法。
If they haven't, that's exactly right. If you have, then it's not an issue.
如果他们没纳税，确实如此。如果你纳税了，那就没问题。
No, I think that would scare me even if I had paid my taxes.
不，我想即使我纳税了，那也会吓到我。
Maybe. Maybe--
也许。也许——
You don't think so? You don't think people-- anybody who gets that is freaked out by it, even if they're completely compliant?
你不这么认为吗？你不认为人们——任何收到这个的人都会感到惊慌，即使他们完全合规？
Yeah, I guess you would be frightened. I guess you would be frightened. I don't look at it that way. But yeah, the average person would probably be frightened.
是的，我想你会害怕的。我想你会害怕的。我不那样看。但是的，一般人可能会害怕。
So what do you think about that?
那么你对此怎么看？
I think if you've done what you should do, you don't worry about it. If you haven't, well, you have the possibility of cleaning up your act before somebody comes knocking on your door.
我想如果你做了你应该做的事，你就不必担心。如果你没做，嗯，你还有机会在别人敲你门之前清理你的行为。
Honestly, I was conflicted about all this. It felt kind of wrong, but I can't say why. Maybe it's that if you turn someone in, you worry that bad things are going to happen to them.
老实说，我对这一切感到矛盾。感觉有点不对，但我说不出为什么。也许是因为如果你检举了某人，你担心坏事会发生在他们身上。
One time I was in this little corner grocery store, and I saw this woman shoplifting. And I went back and forth about whether I should say something. In the end, I did. But my heart was pounding. And as I left I heard the store owner confronting her, and I just felt awful. Squealing-- it doesn't feel like something to be proud of. An Al-- even Al-- he's got complicated feelings about it.
有一次我在一个小拐角杂货店，看到一个女人在商店行窃。我反复考虑是否应该说点什么。最后，我还是说了。但我的心怦怦直跳。当我离开时，听到店主在质问她，我感觉糟透了。告密——这感觉不像是一件值得骄傲的事。而Al——甚至Al——他对它有复杂的感受。
How do you feel about squealing?
你对告密有什么感觉？
If you feel strongly enough about a certain situation, I think you should report it. It's as simple as that. My own personal belief-- would I do it? No.
如果你对某种情况感觉足够强烈，我认为你应该举报它。就这么简单。我个人的信念——我会做吗？不会。
You wouldn't use your own website?
你不会使用你自己的网站？
I would be-- no, I wouldn't do it. I just wouldn't do it, because I don't think-- I just wouldn't do it.
我会——不，我不会做。我只是不会做，因为我不认为——我只是不会做。
Why?
为什么？
It's just not my nature to do those kind of thing.
这不是我做这类事的本性。
Because it feels wrong to you to turn them in?
因为检举他们让你觉得不对？
No, it's just not something I would do. It's not wrong or right.
不，这只是我不会做的事情。它没所谓对错。
No, it's got to be right. It's got to be right to turn them in if they're doing something wrong.
不，这肯定是对的。如果他们做错了什么，检举他们肯定是对的。
It really depends. It depends on the situation. I would have to be directly affected before I would do something like that. I wouldn't do it. I'd sooner approach the person before I did this. The anonymous feature makes it very suspect.
这真的看情况。看情况而定。我必须直接受到影响，我才会做那种事。我不会做。在做这件事之前，我宁愿直接去找那个人谈。匿名功能使它非常可疑。
You're allowing people to do this thing that you yourself wouldn't do.
你在允许人们做你自己不会做的事。
I'm giving the ability to do it. Doesn't mean I choose to do it, right?
我提供了做这件事的能力。不代表我选择做这件事，对吧？
Al's Tax Squeal business is not going as well as he'd hoped. The tax attorneys he thought would pay to advertise on the website? They didn't really materialize. And that $2 "you've been squealed on" postcard service? Most people don't do it. Most people, it turns out, are like Al. They don't want to squeal. Sure, there are lots of vindictive ex-employees and ex-spouses out there eager to squeal, just maybe not enough to support a business. Al says the postage alone is killing him.
Al的税务告密业务进展并不像他希望的那么顺利。他以为会付钱在网站上做广告的税务律师？他们并没有真正出现。而那个2美元的“你已经被举报了”明信片服务？大多数人没用它。事实证明，大多数人就像Al。他们不想告密。当然，外面有很多怀恨在心的前员工和前配偶渴望告密，只是可能没有足够的支持来维持这项业务。Al说光是邮费就在拖垮他。
David Kestenbaum. Normally you can hear him on NPR's Planet Money. Their absolutely free, deeply informative and entertaining podcast is at npr.org/money.
David Kestenbaum。通常你可以在NPR的《Planet Money》上听到他。他们绝对免费、深度且有信息量又娱乐的播客在npr.org/money。
Our show was produced today by Chana Joffe-Walt with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Alison Davis. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Music help from Damien Graef.
我们的节目今天由Chana Joffe-Walt制作，Alex Blumberg、Ben Calhoun、Sean Cole、Stephanie Foo、Sarah Koenig、Miki Meek、Jonathan Menjivar、Brian Reed、Robyn Semien、Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike共同参与。我们的资深制片人是Julie Snyder。Alison Davis提供制作协助。Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elise Bergerson是我们的行政助理。Adrianne Mathiowetz负责我们的网站。Michelle Harris和Julie Beer提供研究协助。Damien Graef提供音乐协助。
Special thanks to doctors Jane DeLima Thomas, Charles DeCarli, Jimo Borjigin, and Lisa Sanders. Thanks also to Bo Burnham. And thanks especially to the staff of the Kaplan House and Care Dimensions, to the patients and family members who spoke with us. Thanks to the Churchill School in New York and the Lucile Packard Children's Hospital in Palo Alto, where we interviewed kids about puberty. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
特别感谢Jane DeLima Thomas、Charles DeCarli、Jimo Borjigin和Lisa Sanders医生。也感谢Bo Burnham。特别感谢Kaplan之家和Care Dimensions的工作人员，感谢接受我们采访的病人和家属。感谢纽约的Churchill学校和帕洛阿尔托的Lucile Packard儿童医院，我们在那里采访了孩子们关于青春期的话题。我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由Public Radio International分发。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He just joined a new health club, and they have a sauna. And he cannot shut up about how great it's going to be when I join.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。他刚加入了一个新的健身俱乐部，他们有一个桑拿房。只要我加入，他就喋喋不休地说那会有多棒。
You're going to smell more bad. You're going to sweat. Sweating more, a lot more.
你会变得更臭。你会出汗。出汗更多，多得多。
Chest hair. Chest hair.
胸毛。胸毛。
OK.
好吧。
Getting really smelly.
变得真的很臭。
Chest hair.
胸毛。
Sweating like a moose.
出汗像头驼鹿。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。